So you've seen some of the responses
we get from these APIs,
and they're kind of unwieldy.
Although they are somewhat readable,
at first glance it's difficult
to extract something useful
from these responses.
But these JSON responses
are easily parsable in Python.
I'm going to call the getGeocodeLocation
function again, but this time,
store the result in
a variable named Dallas.
So when I call Dallas,
I get this huge JSON object again.
Looking at this response,
I can try to better understand the data
that google maps is providing to me.
All of the data that looks like
coordinates is in this portion of
the response.
I see quite a few coordinates though,
so which ones are the ones that I need?
Well, reading through the response,
the first thing I notice
is that Google is giving me
an approximate set of coordinates,
that correspond to the Northeast and
Southwest bounds of the city.
Then it provides a suggested viewport
for viewing the entire city on the map.
But this final set of coordinates seems
to correspond to a central set of
coordinates for the city.
These are the ones
that I want to extract.
By typing dallas.keys
I can navigate through the keys of the
JSON response like a Python dictionary.
In some cases,
I see that keys contain lists of values.
So by using the square brackets,
I can reference to an index
inside of these lists.
After navigating through
this response for
a little bit, I found that going
into results, then the zero's index,
then geometry, location, and lat,
gave me the latitude that I wanted.
Similarly, going down the same path and
then using lng,
returns the longitude
coordinate I wanted.
So I'm finished extracting
just the latitude and
longitude coordinates from
my geocoding request.
I modify my geocode.pie file like so,
such that now it responds the latitude
and longitude coordinates.
I'll also comment out the response
header for now as well.
The code for this activity can be
found in the instructor notes.